So I'm back.
I guess by your
presence here you've
shown that for you people,
DP1 is well under control.
And that's great.
OK, so today is the last lecture
on this topic on the networking
piece of 6.033.
And, the topic for
today is something
called congestion control.
And what we're
going to do is spend
most of today talking
about congestion control.
But let me remind you of
where we are in networking.
And so if there's one
thing you take away
from 6.033 from this
networking piece
you should remember
this picture.
So the way we're
dealing with networking,
and the way we always
deal with networking
in any complicated system is
to layer network protocols.
And the particular learning
model that we picked for 6.033
is a subset of what you'd
see out in the real world.
And it's mostly accurate.
There is something
called the link
layer which deals with
transmitting packets
on the link.
And of that, you have
the network layer.
And, the particular
kind of network layer
that we are talking about
is a very popular one
which provides a kind of service
called a best effort service.
And the easiest way to
understand best effort
services: it just
tries to get packets
through from one end to another.
But it doesn't get all panicked
if it can't get packets
through.
It just lets a higher
layer called the end
to end layer deal with
any problems such as lost
packets, or missing packets,
or corrupted packets,
reordered packets, and so on.
And last time when
Sam gave the lecture,
he talked about a few things
that the end to end layer does.
And in particular we talked
about how the end to end layer
achieves reliability
using acknowledgments.
So the receiver
acknowledges packets
that it receives from the
center, and the sender,
if it misses an acknowledgment
goes ahead and retransmits
the packet.
And in order to do
that, we spent some time
talking about timers
because you have to not try
to retransmit immediately.
You have to wait some
time until you're
pretty sure that the
packet's actually
lost before you go ahead and
try to retransmit the packet.
The next concept at the end to
end layer that we talked about
is something called a sliding
window, where the idea was
that if I send you a packet,
got an acknowledgment back,
and then sent you
the next packet
and did that, things
are really slow.
And all that a
sliding window is,
is really an idea that you've
already seen from an earlier
chapter, and probably from
6.004 called pipelining, which
is to have multiple
outstanding things in the pipe
or in the network at once as a
way to get higher performance.
And the last thing that
we talked about last time
was flow control.
And the idea here
is to make sure
that the sender doesn't send
too fast because if it's
sent really fast, it would
swamp the receiver, which
might be slow trying to keep
up processing the sender's
packets.
So you don't want to swamp
the receiver's buffer.
And we talked about how
with every acknowledgment,
the receiver can
piggyback some information
about how much space it has
remaining in its buffer.
And if that clamped
down to zero,
then the sender would
automatically slow down.
You would produce what's also
known as back pressure back
to the sender's thing.
I don't have any more
space to slow down.
And the sender guarantees that
it won't send more packets
at any given time,
more data at any given
time than what the receiver says
it can handle in its buffer.
So that was the plan.
Those are the things we talked
about so far for the end
to end layer.
And what we're
going to do today is
to go back to one of the main
things about networks that
was mentioned during the
first networking lecture
and talk about how we achieve
that, which is sharing.
Ultimately, it's extremely
inefficient to build networks
where every computer
is connected
to every other
computer in the world
by a dedicated link or a
dedicated path of its own.
Fundamentally,
networks are efficient
only if they allow
computers connected
to each other to share
paths underneath.
And the moment you
have sharing of links,
you have to worry about
sharing the resources,
namely sharing the
bandwidth of a link
and that's what we're
going to do today.
And we're going to do this.
Basically the goal for today is
to talk about the problems that
arise if you don't you
do sharing properly,
and then spend some
time talking about how
we solve these problems.
So imagine you have a network.
And I'm going to start
with a simple example.
And we're going to
use that example
to write through,
because it will turn out
that the simple
example will illustrate
the essential
problem with sharing.
So imagine you have a bunch
of computers connected
to one end of the network.
And at the other end you
have other computers.
And imagine that
these are senders
and these are receivers.
And they share the network.
And you know a really simple
form of sharing this network
might be when you have
all of these computers,
take their links like
the Ethernet connections
and hook them up to a switch.
And maybe you hook it
up to another switch.
And then there's
other paths that
eventually take you
to the receivers
that you want to talk to.
And imagine just for example
that these are fake lengths.
So for example these might
be 100 Mb per second links.
And then you go [SOUND OFF/THEN
ON], and that might be,
let's say it's a
megabit per second link.
So this might be
1 Mb per second.
And these things are
100 Mb per second.
And of course you could
have the receivers connected
with extremely fast
links as well, which
means that if the
sender and the receiver
just looked at their own
access links, these 100
Mb per second links, and just
thought to themselves, well,
I have 100 Mb per second links.
The sender has 100
Mb per second link,
so clearly we could exchange
data at 100 Mb per second.
That would be flawed
because all of these things
go through this relatively thin
pipe of a megabit per second.
So really, the goal
here is to take
all of these connections,
all of these end
to end transfers that might
be happening at any given
point in time, and share every
link in the network properly.
And I'll define what I mean
by properly as we go along.
So let's write
some notation first
because it will help us
pose the problem clearly.
So let's say that
there is some offered
load that these different
senders offered to the network.
So you've decided to
download a bunch of files,
music files, and WebPages.
And each of those
has a certain load
that it's a certain
size of a file.
A sender can actually push
that data through at some rate.
So that's the offered
load on the network.
And let's assume that senders
[want?] through N here,
and let's say that the offered
load of the sender is L1.
This is L2, all
the way through LN.
OK, so in this simple picture,
the total offered load
on the network
along this path is
the summation of LI's, where
I runs from one to N, right?
Hand out here, in
this simple picture,
we have all this offered
load going through this one
common link, which we're going
to call the bottleneck link.
We don't actually know
where; the senders
don't know where the bottleneck
is because it's not near them.
And in general,
it's not near them.
It could be, but in general,
they don't know where it is.
The receivers don't
know where it is.
But there is some
bottleneck link
that's going to throttle the
maximum rate at which you
could send data.
Let's call that rate C.
So what we would
like to be able to do
is ensure that at
all points in time
that the sum of the load
that's being offered
by all senders that
share any given link
is less than the
capacity of that link.
And so, C here, this
picture, this would be C.
And notice that
we don't actually
know where these things are.
And for different connections,
if you are surfing the web
and downloading music and
so on, the actual bottleneck
for each of those transfers
might in general be different.
But the general goal
for congestion control
is you look at any path
between a sender and receiver,
and there is, in general,
some bottleneck there.
And you have to ensure that
for every bottleneck link,
in fact for every
link, the total offered
load presented to that link
satisfies this relationship.
OK, so that's ultimate goal.
[SOUND OFF/THEN ON], OK?
[SOUND OFF/THEN ON] one other
problem, that you want this.
This is not a trivial problem.
So one reason it's
not trivial is
something that might
have been clear to you
from the definition
of the problem.
You want to share this for
all the links in the network.
And the network in general
might have, or will have,
millions of links, and
hundreds of millions of hosts.
So any solution you come
up with has to be scalable.
And in particular, it has to
scale to really large networks,
networks that are as big
as the public Internet,
and the whole public
Internet 10 years from now.
So it has to be
something that scales.
It has to handle large values.
So it has to handle
large networks.
It has to handle large values
of N, where the number of N
to N connections that
are transferring data
on this network, and it's
an unknown value of N.
You don't really know what N
is at any given point in time.
And it could be extremely large.
So you have to handle that.
And above all, and
this is actually
the most important point.
And it's often missed by a lot
of descriptions of congestion
control and sharing.
A good solution has to scale
across many orders of magnitude
of link properties.
On the Internet or in any
decent packet switch network,
link rates vary
by perhaps seven,
or eight, or nine
orders of magnitude.
A single network could have
links that send data in five
or ten kilobits
per second on one
extreme, and 10 Gb per
second, or 40 Gb per second
on the other extreme.
And a single path
might actually go
through links whose
capacities vary
by many orders of magnitude.
And it's extremely
important that a solution
work across this range because
otherwise its generality isn't
that general.
And what you would like is
a very general solution.
The second reason
this problem as
hard is that here
we have this N,
but really N is a
function of time.
You're surfing the Web.
You click on a link, and all
of a sudden 18 embedded objects
come through.
In general, each of those
is a different connection.
And then it's gone.
And the next time somebody
else clicks on something,
there's a bunch more objects.
So N varies with time.
And as a consequence,
the offered load
on the system, both
the total offered load
as well as the load offered
by single connection
varies with time.
So, LI varies with time as well.
So it's kind of really
hard to understand
what the steady-state
behavior of a large network
like the Internet
is because there
is no steady-state behavior.
And [SOUND OFF/THEN ON]
is the thing
that we're going to come back
to and [SOUND OFF/THEN ON]
the person who can control
the rate at which data
is being sent is the sender.
And maybe the receiver
can help it control it
by advertising these
flow control windows.
So the control happens
at these points.
But if you think about it, the
resource that's being shared
is somewhere else.
It's far away, right?
So, there is a delay between
the congestion point,
or the points where
overload happens
with these points
in the network,
and where the control
can be exercised
to control congestion.
And this situation is
extremely different from most
other resource
management schemes
for other computer systems.
If you talk about processor
resource management,
well, there's a schedule
of the controls,
what runs on the processor.
The processor is right there.
There's no long delay
between the two.
So if the operating system
decides to schedule [another?]
process, well, it doesn't take
a long time before that happens.
It happens pretty quickly.
And nothing else usually
happens in the meantime
related to something
else, some other process.
If you talk about
disk scheduling,
well, the disk scheduler is
very, very close to the disk.
It can make a
decision, and exercises
control according to whatever
policy that it wants.
Here, if the network
decides it's congested,
and there is some plan
by which the network will
want to react to that load,
well, it can't do very much.
It has to somehow
arrange for feedback
to reach the points of control,
which are in general far away,
and are not just far
away in terms of delay,
but that delay varies as well.
That's what makes
the problem hard,
which is that the resource is
far from the control point.
So these are the
congestion points, which
is where the resources are.
And these are the
control points, which
is where you can exercise.
And the two are
separated geographically.
I don't think I mentioned this.
This is what you want.
And any situation where
the summation of LI,
the offered load on a link,
is larger than the capacity,
that overload situation is what
we're going to call congestion.
OK, so any time you
see LI bigger than C,
we're going to define
that as congestion.
And then, I'll make this notion
a little bit more precise.
And you'll see why we have to
make it slightly more precise.
But for now, just say that
if inequality is swapped,
that means it's congested.
OK, so that's the problem.
We are going to want
to solve the problem.
Now, every other problem that
we've encountered in networking
so far, we've solved by going
back to that layered picture
and saying, well, we need
to deliver, for example,
if you want to deliver
packets across one link,
we say all right, we'll take
this thing as a link layer
protocol.
We'll define framing
on top of it,
and define a way by
which we can do things
like [UNINTELLIGIBLE] correction
if we need to on that link,
and we'll solve the
problem right there.
Then we say, OK, we need to
connect all these computers up
together and build up routing
tables so we can forward data.
And we say, OK, that's the
network layer's problem.
We're going to solve
the problem there.
And then packets get lost.
Well, we'll deal with it
at the end to end layer.
And, that model has
worked out extremely well
because it allows us to run
arbitrary applications on top
of this network layer
without really having
to build up forwarding
tables for every application
anew and run it on
all sorts of links.
And you can have
paths containing
a variety of different links.
And everything works
out like a charm.
But the problem with doing
that for congestion control
is that this layered
picture is actually
getting in the way
of solving congestion
control in a very clean manner.
And the reason for that is
that the end to end layer runs
at the end points.
And those are the
points were control
is exercised to control the
rate at which traffic is
being sent on to the network.
But the congestion,
and the notice
of any information about whether
the network is overloaded
is deeply buried inside the
network at the network layer.
So, what you need is a
way by which information
from the network layer
about whether congestion
is occurring, or whether
congestion is not occurring,
or whether congestion is likely
to occur even though it's not
yet occurred, that
kind of information
has somehow to percolate
toward the end to end layer.
And so far, we've
modularized this very nicely
by not really having
very much information
propagate between the layers.
But now, to solve this problem
of congestion, precisely
because this separation between
the resource and the control
point, and the fact that the
control point is at the end
to end layer, at
least in the way
we're going to
solve the problem.
And the fact that the
resources at the network layer,
it necessitates across layer
solution to the problem.
So somehow we need information
to move between the two layers.
So here's a general plan.
So we're going to arrange for
them to end layer at the sender
to send at a rate.
This is going to be a rate
that changes with time.
But let's say that the
sender at some point in time
sends at a rate, RI where RI
is measured in bits per second.
And that's actually true here.
In case it wasn't clear, these
loads are in bits per second.
The capacity is in bits
per second as well.
So the plan is for the sender to
send at a [layered?] rate, RI.
And, for all of the switches
inside the network, to keep
track in some fashion of
whether they are being congested
or not, and it's going to
be really simple after that.
If the senders are
sending too fast,
or if a given sender
is sending too fast,
then we're going to
tell them to slow down.
The network layer is somehow
going to tell the sender
to slow down.
And likewise, if they
are sending too slow,
and we have yet
to figure out how
you know that you're
sending too slow,
and that you could
send a little faster,
you're sending too
slow there's going
to be some plan by which
the sender can speed up.
And the nature of
our solution is
going to be that
there is really not
going to be a steady
rate at which senders
are going to send.
In fact, by the
definition of the problem,
the steady rate is a [fool's
errand?] because N varies N
varies and the load varies.
So that means on any given link,
the traffic varies with time.
So you really don't
want a static rate.
What you would like to do is
if there's any extra capacity,
and the sender has load
to fill that capacity,
you want that sender
to use that capacity.
So this rate is going
to adapt and change
with time in response
to some feedback
that we're going to obtain based
on network layer information
essentially from the network
layer about whether people
are sending too fast or
people are sending too slow.
OK and all congestion
control schemes
that people have come
up with, all algorithms
for solving this problem,
and there have been dozens
if not a few
hundred of them, all
of these things in various
variants of various solutions,
all of them are according
to the basic plan.
OK, the network layer
gives some feedback.
If it's too fast, slow down.
If it's too slow, speed up.
The analogy is a little bit
like a water pipeline network.
Imagine have all sorts of
pipes feeding water in.
You have this massive
pipeline network.
And what you can control are
the valves at the end points.
And by controlling
the valves, you
can decide whether to
let water rush in or not.
And anytime you're
getting clogged,
you have to slow down
and close the valves.
So the devil's actually
in the details.
So were going to dive in to
actually seeing how we're
going to solve this problem.
And the first component of any
solution to congestion control
is something we've already seen.
And it's buffering.
Any network that has
asynchronous multiplex
and, which Sam talked about the
first time, any network that
has the following behavior,
at any given point in time you
might have multiple packets
arrive in to a given switch.
And, the switch can
only send one of them
out on an outgoing link at
any given point in time, which
means if you
weren't careful, you
would have to drop the
other packet that showed up.
And so, almost
everyone who builds
a decent asynchronously
multiplex network
puts in some queues
to buffer packets
until the link is free so they
can then send the packet out
onto the link.
So the key question
when it comes
to buffering but you
have to ask is how much?
I don't actually mean how
much in terms of how expensive
it is, but in terms of how
much should the buffering be?
Should you have one
packet of buffering?
Two packets?
Four packets?
And how big should
the buffer be?
Well, the one way to answer
the question of how much,
first you can ask, what
happens if it's too little?
So what happens if the buffering
is too little in a switch?
Like you put one
packet or two packets
of buffering: what happens?
I'm sorry, what?
Well, congestion by
definition has happened when
the load exceeds the capacity.
So you get congestion.
But what's the effect of that?
So a bunch of packets show up.
You've got two
packets of buffering.
[So you could lose?] packets.
This is pretty clear, right?
Good.
So if it's too
little, what ends up
happening is that
you drop packets,
which suggests that you can't
have too little buffering, OK?
So, at the other
end of the spectrum,
you could just say,
well, I'm going
to design my network so
it never drops a packet.
Memory is cheap.
We learned about Moore's Law.
So let's just over provision,
also called too much buffering.
OK, it's not really
that expensive.
So what happens if there's
too much buffering?
Well, if you think
about it, the only thing
that happens when you have too
much buffering as well, packets
won't get lost.
But all you've
done is traded off
packet loss for packet delay.
Adding more buffering doesn't
make your link go any faster.
They should probably
learn that at Disneyland
and places like that.
I mean, these lines
there are just so long.
I mean, they may
as well tell people
to go away and come back later.
It's the same principle.
I mean, just adding longer
lines and longer queues
doesn't mean that the
link goes any faster.
So it's really problematic
to add excessive buffers.
And the reason is quite subtle.
The reason it actually
has to do with something
we talked about the last
time, or at lease one reason,
a critical reason has to do
with timers and retransmissions.
Recall that all you do when
you have too much buffering
is you eliminate packet loss
or at least reduce it greatly
at the expense of
increasing delays.
But the problem with
increasing delays
is that your timers that you're
trying to set up to figure out
when to retransmit a
packet, you would like them
to adapt to increasing delays.
So he you build this
exponentially weighted
moving average, and you pick
a timeout interval that's
based on the mean value,
and the standard deviation.
And the problem with
too much buffering
is that it makes these
adaptive timers extremely
hard to implement
because your timeout
value has to depend on both the
mean and standard deviation.
And if you have
too much buffering,
the range of round-trip
time values is too high.
And the result of
that you end up
with this potential
for something
called congestion collapse.
And let me explain
this with a picture.
So your adaptive
timers are trying
to estimate the round-trip time,
and the average round-trip time
in the standard deviation
or at the linear deviation
of the round-trip time,
and at some point they're
going to make a decision
as to whether to retransmit
a packet or not.
What might happen,
and what does happen
and has happened when you have
too much networks with too
much buffering is
that you end up
with a queue that's really big.
OK, and this is some link on
which the packet's going out,
and you might have
packet one sitting here,
and two sitting here, and
three, and all the way out.
There is a large number
of packets sitting there.
Notice that the
end to end sender
is trying to decide
whether packet one
for whose acknowledgment
it still hasn't heard.
It's trying to decide whether
one is still in transit,
or has actually been dropped.
And it should
retransmit the packet
only after one has been dropped.
But if you have
too much buffering,
the range of these
values is so high
that it makes these adaptive
timers quite difficult to tune.
And the result often is that
one is still sitting here.
But it had been stuck behind
a large number of packets.
So the delay was extremely long.
And the end to end
sender timed out.
And when it times out, get
retransmits one into the queue.
And, soon after
that, often it might
retransmit two, and retransmit
three, and retransmit four,
and so on.
And these packets are sort
of just stuck in the queue.
They're not actually lost.
And if you think about
what will happen then,
this link, which is already a
congested link, because queues
have been building up here, long
queues have been building up,
this link is not starting to use
more and more of its capacity
to send the same packet twice,
right, because it sent one out.
And the sender
retransmitted it thinking
it was lost when it was just
stuck behind a long queue.
And now one is being sent again.
And two is being sent
again, and so on.
And graphically, if you look
at this, what you end up with
is a picture that looks
like the following.
This picture plots the total
offered load on the X axis,
and the throughput of
the system on the Y
axis where the
throughput is defined
as the number of useful bits
per second that you get.
So if you send the
packet one twice,
only one of those packets
is actually useful.
Now, initially when
the offered load is low
and the network
is not congested,
and the offered load is less
than the capacity of the link,
this curve is just a
straight line with slope one,
right, because
everything you offer
is below the link's capacity.
And it's going through.
Now at some point, it hits
the link's capacity, right,
the bottleneck link's capacity.
And after that, any
extra offered load
that you pump into
the network is not
going to go out any faster.
The throughput is still
going to remain the same.
And, it's just going
to be flat for a while.
And the reason it's flat is
that queues are building up.
And, that's one reason that you
can't send things any faster.
The only thing that's going on
is that queues are building up.
So this curve remains flat.
Now, in a decent network
that doesn't have congestion
collapse, if you don't
do anything else,
but somehow manage to keep
the system working here,
this curve might
remain flat forever.
No matter what the
offered load, you know,
you can pump more and
more load in the system.
And the throughput remains
flat at the capacity.
But the problem is that
it has interactions
with things that the
higher layer is are doing,
such as these
retransmissions and timers.
And, eventually, more
and more of the capacity
starts being used uselessly for
these redundant transmissions.
And you might end
up in a situation
where the throughput dies down.
OK, and if that
happens, this situation
is called congestion collapse.
There is more and more work
being presented to the system.
If you reach a situation
where the actual amount
of useful work that's
been done starts
reducing as more work gets
presented to the system,
that's the situation
of congestion collapse.
And this kind of thing shows
up in many other systems,
for example, in things like
Web servers that are built out
of many stages where you have
a high load presented [at?]
the system, you might
see congestion collapse
in situations where, let's
say you get a Web request.
And what you have to
do is seven stages
of processing on
the Web request.
But what you do
with the processor
is you take a request,
and you process it
for three of those stages.
And then you decide to
go to the next request
and process at three stages.
And, you go to the next request
[that?] passes at three stages.
So, [no?] request gets complete.
Your CPU's 100% utilized.
But the throughput
is essentially
diving down to zero.
That's another situation where
you have congestion collapse.
But when it occurs
in networks, it
turns out it's more complicated
to solve the networks because
of these reasons that
I outlined before.
So has everyone seen this?
So let's go back to our problem.
Our goal is to, we want
this thing to be true.
The aggregate offered
load to be smaller
than the capacity of a link
for every link in the system.
But it turns out that's not
enough of a specification
because there are many
ways to achieve this goal.
For example, a really cheesy
way to achieve this goal
is to make sure that
everybody remains quiet.
If nobody sends
any packets, you're
going to get that to be true.
So we're going to actually
have to define the problem
a little bit more completely.
And let's first define
what we don't want.
The first thing we don't
want is congestion collapse.
So any solution should have
the property that it never
gets into that situation.
And in fact, good
congestion control schemes
operate at the left
knee of the curve.
But we're not going
to get too hung up
on that because if we operate
a little bit in the middle,
we're going to say that's
fine because that'll turn out
to be good enough in practice.
And often is just fine.
And the additional complexity
that you might have to bring
to bear on a solution to work
nearer [the knee?] might not be
worth it.
OK, but really
we're going to worry
about not falling off the
cliff at the right edge, OK?
And then having done
that, we're going
to want reasonable utilization
also called efficiency.
So, what this says is that if
you have a network link that's
often congested, you
want to make sure
that that link isn't
underutilized when
there is offered load around.
So for example,
people are presenting
100 kb per second of
load, and the network link
has that capacity; you
want that to be used.
You don't want to
shut them up too much.
So what this really
means in practice
is that if you have slowed
down, and excess capacity
has presented
itself, then you have
to make sure that you speed up.
So that's what it
means in practice.
And the third part
of the solution
is there's another thing
we need to specify.
And the reason is that you
can solve these two problems
by making sure that only
one person transmits
in the network.
OK, if that person has
enough offered load,
then you just got
everybody out altogether,
and essentially
allocate that resource
in sort of a monopolistic
fashion to this one person.
That's not going to be
very good because we
would like our network to be
used by a number of people.
So I'm going to define that as
a goal of any good solution.
I'm going to call it
equitable allocation.
I'm not going to say fair
allocation because fair
suggests that it's
really a strong condition
that every connection gets a
roughly equal throughput if it
has that offered load.
I mean, that turns out to
be, I think, in my opinion,
achieving perfect fairness
to TCP connections
is just a waste of time
because in reality, fairness
is governed by who's paying
what for access to the network.
So we're not going to get
into that in this class.
But we are going to want
solutions that don't eliminate,
don't starve certain
connections out.
And we'll be happy
with that because that
will turn out to work out
just fine in practice.
Now, to understand this
problem a little bit better,
we're going to want to
understand this requirement
a little bit more closely.
And the problem is
that this requirement
of the aggregate rate
specified by the offered load,
being smaller than
the link capacity is
a condition on rates.
It just says the offered
load is 100 kb per second.
The capacity is
150 kb per second.
That means it's fine.
The problem is that you
have to really ask offered
load over what timescale?
For example, if the overall
offered load on your network
is, let's say, a
megabit per second,
and the capacity of the network
is half a megabit per second,
and in that condition
lasts for a whole day,
OK, so for a whole day, your
website got slash dotted.
Take that example.
And you have this
little wimpy access link
through your DSL line.
And, ten times that much
in terms of requests
are being presented
to your website.
And, it lasts for the whole day.
Guess what.
Nothing we're
going to talk about
is really going to
solve that problem
in a way that allows every
request to get through
in a timely fashion.
At some point, you throw up your
hands and say, you know what?
If I want my website
to be popular,
I'd better put it on a
10 Mb per second network
and make sure that everybody
can gain access to it.
So we're not really going to
solve the problem at that time
scale.
On the other hand, if
your website suddenly
got a little bit popular,
and a bunch of connections
came to it, but it didn't
last for a whole day,
but it lasted for a
few seconds, we're
going to want to deal
with that problem.
So if you think about it,
there are three timescales
that matter here.
And these timescales
arise in an actual way
because of this network where
congestion happens here.
And then we're going to
have some feedback, go back
to the sender, and the
sender exercises control.
And the only timescale
in this whole system
is the round-trip
time because that's
the timescale, the
order of magnitude
of the timescale around
which any feedback is
going to come to us.
So there are three
timescales of interest.
There is smaller than
one round-trip time,
which says this inequality is
not satisfied for really small.
The time where there is
a little spurt, a burst,
it's also called a burst,
a burst of packets show up,
and then you have
to handle them.
But then after that,
things get to be fine.
So there is smaller than
one round-trip time.
So this is summation LI
is greater than C, i.e.
the network is congested.
It could be congested at
really short durations that are
smaller than a roundtrip time.
It could be between
one and I'm going
to say 100 round-trip times.
And just for real
numbers, a round-trip time
is typically order of 100 ms.
So we are talking here
of less than 100 ms up
to about ten seconds, and then
bigger than this number, OK?
Bigger than 100.
And these are all
orders of magnitude.
I mean, it could be 500 RTT's.
OK, those are the three
time scales to worry about.
When congestion happens at
less than one roundtrip time,
we're going to solve that
problem using this technique.
We're going to solve
it using buffering, OK?
And, that's the plan.
The reason is that it's really
hard to do anything else
because the congestion
lasts for certain burst.
And by the time you
figure that out and tell
the sender of that,
the congestion
has gone away, which
means telling the sender
that the congestion
has gone away,
which means telling the sender
that the congestion has gone
away was sort of a waste
because the sender would
have slowed down.
But the congestion
anyway went away.
So, why bother, right?
Why did you tell
the sender that?
So that's the kind
of thing you want
to solve at the network
layer inside the switches.
And that's going to be
done using buffering.
And that sort of
suggests, and there's
a bit of sleight-of-hand here.
And we're not going
to talk about why
there's a sleight-of-hand.
But this really suggests
that if you design a network
and you want to put
buffering in the network,
you'd better not put more than
about a round-trip time's worth
of buffering in that switch.
If you put buffering longer
than a round-trip time,
you're getting in
the way of things
that the higher layers
are going to be doing.
And it's going to confuse them.
In fact, Sam showed
you this picture
of these round-trip
times varying
a lot between the last
lecture where the mean was
two and a half seconds.
And the standard deviation
was one and a half seconds.
That was not a made-up picture.
That was from a real
wireless network
where the designers
had incorrectly
put a huge amount of buffering.
And this is extremely common.
Almost every modem that you buy,
cellular modem or phone modem,
has way too much
buffering in it.
And, the only thing that happens
is these queues build up.
It's just a mistake.
So less than one roundtrip time:
deal with it using buffering.
Between one and 100
round-trip times,
we're going to deal with that
problem using the techniques
that we are going to talk about
today, the next five or ten
minutes.
And then bigger than 100
round-trip times or 1,000
round-trip times are things
where congestion is just
sort of persistent for many,
many, many seconds or minutes
or hours.
And there are ways of dealing
with this problem using
protocols and using algorithms.
But ultimately you have to ask
yourself whether you are really
under provisioned,
and you really
ought to be buying or
provisioning your network
to be higher, maybe put
your [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
on a different network
that has higher capacity.
And these are longer
times congestion effects
for which decisions
based on provisioning
have to probably come to
play in solving the problem.
So, provisioning is certainly
an important problem.
And when you have
congestion lasting
really long periods
of time, that
might be the right solution.
But for everything
else, there is
solutions that are much easier
to understand, or at least as
far as using the tools that
we've built so far in 6.033.
So, the first component
of the solution
is some buffering to deal
with the smaller than one
round-trip time situation.
And then when your buffers
start getting filled up,
and congestion is lasting for
more than a round-trip time,
then your buffers start
getting filled up.
At that point, you're starting
to see congestion that can't
be hidden by pure buffering.
And that can't be hidden
because queues are building up,
and that's causing increased
delay to show up at the sender,
and perhaps packets may
start getting dropped
when the queue overflows.
And that causes the sender to
observe this congestion, which
means that what we want
is a plan by which,
when congestion happens lasting
over half a round-trip time
or close to a
round-trip time, we're
going to want to provide
feedback to the sender, OK?
And then the third
part of our solution
is when the sender gets this
feedback, what it's going to do
is adapt.
And the way it's going to
adapt is actually easy.
It's going to do it by
modifying the rate at which it
sends packets.
And that's what are set up.
The sender sends at rate RI.
What you do is you change
the rate or the speed
at which the sender sends.
So, there's two things
we have to figure out.
One is, how does the
network give feedback?
And the second is, what
exactly is going on
with changing the speed?
How does it work?
There are many ways
to give feedback,
and sort of the first order of
things you might think about
are, well, when the
queue starts to fill up,
I'll send a message
to the sender,
or I'll send a bit in the packet
header and get to the endpoint,
and it'll send
this feedback back.
And any variant that you can
think of in the next five
or ten minutes I can assure
you has been thought of
and investigated.
And you might think
of new ways of doing
it which would be great.
I mean, this is a
topic of active work.
People are working
on this stuff still.
But my opinion is
that the best way
to solve this
problem of feedback
is the simplest possible
thing you could think of.
The simplest technique that
really works all the time
is just drop the packet.
In particular, if the
queue overflows, and it's
going to get dropped anyway,
and that's a sign of congestion,
but if at any point in time
you decide that the network is
getting congested and remains
so for a long enough time scale
that you want the
sender to react,
just throw the packet away.
The last thing about
throwing a packet
away is that it's extremely
hard to implement it wrong
because when the
queue overflows,
the packet's going
to be dropped anyway.
So that feedback is going to be
made available to the sender.
So what we're going
to assume for now
is that all packet drops
that happen in networks
are a sign of congestion, OK?
And when a packet gets dropped,
the sender gets that feedback.
And, the reason it
gets that feedback is,
remember that every
packet's being acknowledged.
So if it misses
an acknowledgment,
then it knows that the
packet's been dropped.
And it says, ah, the
network is congested.
And then I'm going
to change my speed.
And, I'm going to
change my speed
by reducing the rate at which
I'm going to send packets.
So now, we have to ask
how the sender adapts
to congestion, how the speed
thing actually works out.
Well?
It says up.
It's already up.
Yeah, it doesn't
have a down button.
What's that?
Sam?
How many professors
does it take to --
He turned the thing off.
He turned the light off on that.
This might actually work.
Can you see that?
I bet it's a race condition.
All right, so, can you see that?
OK, let's just move from here.
OK, the way we're
going to figure out
the rate at which we're
going to send our packets
is to use this idea
of a sliding window
that we talked
about the last time.
And since Sam did
such a nice animation,
I'm going to display that
again, just a refresher.
Wonderful.
All right.
[APPLAUSE] And since Sam
made this nice animation,
I'm going to play that back.
I've always wanted to
say, play it again, Sam.
So, what's going on
here is that whenever
the receiver
receives a packet, it
sends in acknowledgment back.
And the sender's pipelining
packets going through.
And whatever the sender
gets an acknowledgment,
it sends a new packet off.
And that's where
you see happening.
Whenever it gets
an acknowledgment,
a new packet goes out
onto the other end.
And, the window's
sliding by one every time
it gets an acknowledgement.
So this is sort of the way in
which this steady-state thing
works out for us
in this network.
So the main point
to note about this
is that this scheme
has an effect
that I'll call self pacing.
OK, it's self pacing because
the sender doesn't actually
have to worry very much
about when it should exactly
send a packet because
it's being told
every time an
acknowledgment arrives,
it's being told that the reason
I got an acknowledgment is
because one packet left the
network, which means I can send
one packet into the network.
And as long as things
weren't congested before,
they won't be
congested now, right,
because packets
have left the pipe.
For every packet that leaves,
you're putting one packet in.
This is an absolutely beautiful
idea called self-pacing.
And, the idea here is that
[acts?] essentially [strobe?]
data packets.
And, like all a
really nice ideas,
it's extremely simple to get it.
And it turns out to have
lots of implications
for why the congestion
control system is actually
stable in reality.
So what this means,
for example, is let's
say that things are fine.
And, all of a sudden
a bunch of packets
come in from somewhere
else, and the network
starts to get congested.
What's going to
happen is that queues
are going to start building up.
But, when queues start
building up, what happens
is that transmissions that are
ongoing for this connection
are just going to slow down
a little bit because they're
going to get interleaved
with other packets
in the queue, which means the
acts are going to come back
slower because how
can the acts come back
any faster than the network
can deliver them, which means
automatically the sender has
a slowing down effect dealing
with transient congestion.
This is a really,
really nice behavior.
And as a consequence
of the way in which
the self pacing of, the way
in which the sliding window
thing here works.
So now, at some point the
network might become congested,
and a packet may get dropped.
So, the way that manifests
itself as one packet gets
dropped, the corresponding
acknowledgment
doesn't get back to the sender.
And when an acknowledgment
doesn't get back
to the sender, what
the sender does
is reduce its
window size by two.
OK, so I should mention here
there are really two windows
going on.
One window is the window that
we talked about last time
where the receiver tells the
sender how much buffer space
that it has.
And the other window,
another variable
that we just introduced which
is maintained by the sender,
and it's also called the
congestion window, OK?
And this is a
dynamic variable that
constantly changing as
the sender gets feedback
from the receiver.
And in response to
a missing act when
you determine that
a packet is lost,
you say its congestion
is going on.
And I want to reduce
my window size.
And there are many
ways to reduce it.
We're going to just
multiplicatively decrease it.
And the reason for that
has to do with the reason
why, for example,
on the Ethernet
you found that you were
doing exponential back off.
You're sort of
geometrically increasing
the spacing with which you
are sending packets there.
You're doing the
same kind of thing
here reducing the rate
by a factor of two.
So that's how you slowdown.
At some point you might
get in a situation
where no acknowledgments
come back for a while.
Say, many packets
gets lost, right?
And that could happen.
All of a sudden there's a
lot of congestion going on.
You get nothing back.
At that point, you've lost this
ability for acknowledgments
to strobe new data packets.
OK, so the acts have acted
as a clock allowing you
to strobe packets through.
And you've lost that.
At this point, your best
plan is just to stop.
And you halt for a while.
It's also called a
timeout where you just
be quiet for awhile, often on
the order of a second or more.
And then you try to
start over again.
Of course, now we have to figure
out how you start over again.
And that's the same
problem you have
when you start a connection
in the beginning.
When a connection starts up, how
does it know how fast to send?
It's the same problem as when
many, many packet drops happen,
and you timeout.
And, in TCP, that startup is
done using something called,
a technique called slow start.
And I'll describe the algorithm.
It's a really elegant algorithm,
and it's very, very simple
to implement.
So you have a
sender and receiver.
And the plan is
initially, the sender
wants to initiate a
connection to the receiver.
It sends a request.
It gets the response back
with the flow control window.
It just says how much
buffer space the receiver
currently has.
OK, we're not going to use
that anymore in this picture.
But it's just
there saying, which
means the sender can never
send more than eight packets
within any given roundtrip.
Then what happens is the
sender sends the first segment,
and it gets an act.
So, initially this congestion
window value starts off at one.
OK, so you send one packet.
One segment, you get
an acknowledgment back.
And now the plan is that
the algorithm is as follows.
For every acknowledgment
you get back,
you increase the
congestion window by one.
OK, so what this means is when
you get this acknowledgment
back, you send out two packets.
And each of those two
packets and sends you
back two acknowledgements.
Now, for each of those
two acknowledgements,
you increase the
window by one, which
means that after you got
both those acknowledgements,
you've increased
your window by two.
In previously, the
window was two.
So, now you can
send four packets.
So what happens is in response
to the rape acknowledgment,
you send out two packets.
In response to the light
blue acknowledgement,
you send out two more packets.
And now, those get
through to the other side,
they send back
acknowledgments to you.
In response to
each one of those,
you increase the window by one.
So increasing the window by
one on each acknowledgment
means you can send two packets.
The reason is that one
packet went through.
And you got an acknowledgment.
So in response to
the acknowledgment,
you could send
one packet to fill
in the space occupied
by the packet that
just got acknowledged.
In addition, you
increase the window
by one, which means you
can send one more packet.
So really, what's going
on with this algorithm is
if on each act, you
send two segments, which
means you increase
the window by one,
the congestion window by
one, really what happens
is the rate at which this window
opens is exponential in time
because in every roundtrip,
from one roundtrip to the next,
you're doubling the
entire window, OK?
So although it's called slow
start, it's really quite fast.
And, it's an
exponential increase.
So if you put it
all together, it
will turn out that the way in
which algorithms like the TCP
algorithm works is it starts
off at a value of the congestion
window.
If this is the congestion
window, and this is time,
it starts off at some
small value like one.
And, it increases exponentially.
And then, if you continually
increase exponentially,
this is a recipe for congestion.
It's surely going to overflow
some buffer and slowdown.
So what really happens in
practice is after a while,
based on some threshold, it
just automatically decides
it's probably not worth
going exponentially fast.
And, it turns out slows down
to go at a linear increase.
So every round-trip time
it's increasing the window
by a constant amount.
And then at some point,
congestion might happen.
And when congestion
happens, we drop the window
by a factor of two.
So, we cut down to a factor
of two of the current window.
And then, we continue
to increase linearly.
And then you might have
congestion coming again.
For instance, we might have lost
all of the acknowledgements,
not got any of the
acknowledgements,
losing a lot of packets, which
means we go down to this thing
where we've lost the act clock.
So, we have to time out.
And, it's like a new connection.
So, we remain
silent for a while.
And this period is
the time out period
that's governed by the
equations that we talked
about the last time based
on the roundtrip time
and the standard deviation.
We remain quiet for a while,
and then we start over
as if it's a new connection.
And we increase exponentially.
And this time, we
don't exponentially
increase as we did
the very first time.
We actually exponentially
increase only for a little bit
because we knew that
congestion happened here.
So, we go up to some
fraction of that, and then
increase linearly.
So the exact details
are not important.
The thing that's important is
just understanding that when
congestion occurs, you will drop
your window by a factor [of?]
some multiplicative degrees.
And at the beginning
of connection,
you're trying to quickly
figure out what the sustainable
capacity is.
So he you are going in
this increase phase here.
But after awhile,
you don't really
want to be exponentially
increasing all the time
because that's almost
guaranteed to overrun buffers.
So you want to go into
a more [ginger mode?].
And, people have proposed
congestion control schemes
that do all sorts of things,
all sorts of functions.
But this is the
thing that's just out
there on all of the computers.
And it works remarkably well.
So, there's two basic points
you have to take home from here.
The main goal of
congestion control
is to avoid congestion
collapse, which
is the picture that's being
hidden behind that, which
is that as often
load increases, you
don't want throughput
to drop like a cliff.
And this is a cross
layer problem.
And the essence of
all solutions is
to use a combination of network
layer feedback and end system
control, end to end control.
And, good solutions
work across eight orders
of magnitude of
bandwidth, and four orders
of magnitude of delay.
So, with that, we'll start.
DP1 is due tomorrow.
Have a great spring break, and
see you after spring break.